what did you do to my psychic we merely  slipped you package into your lower  tummy and you're going to transport  something very special to us  yes yes take me the hospital now  somebody put a bag of drugs inside man I  need you to take it out it's leaking it  is estimated most human beings only use  10% of the brain's capacity imagine if  we could access 100% interesting things  begin to happen yes professor Norman my  name is Lucy I just read all your  research on the human brain it's a  little rudimentary but you're on the  right track I thank you I've access to  28% of my cerebral capacity I can feel  everything apart since when did you  start writing cheney's no ago  what happens when she reaches 100% have  no idea all this knowledge given unlock  secrets that go beyond our universe I'm  not even sure that mankind is medicine  it's like all things that make me human  are fading away